my friend
over there in the red jacket uh he's
going through a crisis in life
he's very different he's got his hands
in his pocket because he's uncomfortable
okay so he just needs something yeah you
can change
he might possibly change his life around
and make him
you know you're dealing with everything
what are okay let me ask you a question
what are the
like let's say the most common uh
problems you you face as a
like what are the issues that you
societal issues that you keep
like i keep coming up yeah um
and there's a lot going on i would say
you know if i could boil it down to
maybe a few i would say
people not trusting their instincts yeah
um
people feeling like there's a certain
way to be sexually
whether that's their family that told
them
or usually multiple people's sources and
then
what do you mean by that can you expand
on that a little bit like
that oh no thank you that's the next few
things
so you're asking what is it what do i
mean by messages that we're talking
about no no
give me like more like a case study so
you're saying people like maybe they're
not aware of
they're not confident in themselves or
what is it exactly they're being told by
multiple sources that what they're being
told
yeah confident in ourselves is another
way to look at it i look at it that's
one of our biggest challenges that
people tell us how we're supposed to be
about
sex or our bodies our health okay not
perform or feel or not feel
and we quickly believe that you know
sometimes at age three or four or five
or fifteen
or thirty whatever it is uh and it's
hard to shake that so you might have an
instinct like
i just want to masturbate and that might
be your thing
some people are like you should also be
wanting to get married to this type of
person
and be having this type of sex with them
once a week or twice a week but you
might be thinking i just want to
masturbate whatever it may be
you have your own beliefs about what
works for you is pornography a big
theme here in your work because not
necessarily is it not
so people certainly use it
doesn't come up but i think that usually
people have more
questions around interpersonal uh
and porn is usually not interpersonal if
porn is in some way interpersonal it's
more the interpersonal reaction or
someone's
you know coming up against what works or
doesn't work for them or someone else
if i can ask you a question um do you
find that there's a
in terms of males and females age groups
different demographics
who seems to be like let's say for
example tends to exhibit